hey how's it going everyone minute Felix
today we're going to play a game on the
iPad it's really really cool oh hi I'm
not gonna say what's so cool about it
yet but basically you're this little
creature guy and space dildo whatever
you want it to be it is pretty much but
the gist of the game which I hope will
come in a few minutes maybe
but yeah until then you built these
[ __ ] towers it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing oh my god it's a Mexican UFO he
says hi uh how do I reply huh oh my god
what are you doing Mexican UFO help me
help me Mexican UFO so Mexican UFO is
another player online it's kind of like
journey if you ever play that game on
ps4 ps3 so now me and Mexican UFO have
to work together to make blocks Thank
You Mexican UFO you did bad
alright alright alright I'll get this
one Mexican you phone you'll get the
other one alright great that is one
beautiful tower oh three players what
the hell hahahaha okay hello
hey this is so weird
fancy meeting you guys here oh [ __ ] this
is getting complicated isn't it alright
I'll put this one here where did the
other guy go
sorry Mexican Sorry Sorry I got this I
got this no I got this Mexican look it's
perfect like that why are you moving it
fine fine I'll take this one that's how
I was gonna put it what are you doing
Mexican look at that [ __ ] the [ __ ] is
wrong with him or her yeah yeah that's
better
oh my god yeah no get give it give it
give it to me give it to me oh my god
our coordination skills are on point
there there there nope go up go up go up
go up go up yes
weird edit Mexican power I love Mexicans
by the way I do I want to point that out
Mexicans are my favorite race which oh
my god comes right after white people
there it is we did it buddy we did it
that's amazing he's not the smartest but
he gets the job done I don't know why
it's so cool to have like this basic
interaction with people on line
this hints just knowing that there's
another human being playing the other
player just makes it cool somehow all
right give her some you gotta give us
some trickier puzzles man oh [ __ ] I
can't they can't say that I can't stay
there Mexican somebody gonna have to
dude I got it let it go what do you want
what do you want Mexican what do you
want what are you doing with it what is
he trying to do all right I'll go down
I'll go down yes and then let it go
and then we work together forever
you stay in Mahana will Mexican my best
friend now makes again I'm sorry Mexican
no but for what I mexicana oh yay he's
well pissed ha ha ah thank God we get
some help
come here little turtle man we need you
we need you badly
put it down Mexican put it down down no
Mexican no what did you do
damn it the [ __ ] is he's just gonna
watch could put it down that properly
Mexican no way I'm gonna get well pissed
chato
what is it alright let it go let it go
let it go let it go what are you doing I
had it what a [ __ ] troll let the
Mexican and pills do this just go away
huh
hello no I'm sorry may connect jam it
it's okay I got it I got it all right
all right careful Mexican friend
don't let the turtle [ __ ] do it again
oh my god we did it
ah [ __ ] this is awesome
yes oh [ __ ] is gonna be trickier
I hope Mexican stays with me forever
okay we can't move the black one we're
just gonna work together to pull it over
hello I think that's like I love you in
in Mexican we solve that one fast I
think we're a Power Team
we're like a power couple like selena
and Justin Bieber I mean like now we can
say yay to each other yay I'm enjoying
this more than I probably should
yay yay Mexican and purple dildo forever
and ever
that's a pink dildo damn it oh [ __ ] this
this looks tricky Mexican what should we
do um okay I get it I get it
now mix again no no no mix again Mexican
no no no put it back
no not Mexican mix it okay I know I got
you you were right sorry you're right
all right now we do it okay I get it
ma'am Mexican you're getting smarter man
what do you got like IQ plus some [ __ ]
look at a hair radius
there's the mix damn it it's not
reaching is it it did it yeah good job
Mexican Wow yay yay Mexican and periods
best friends forever they saw parcels
together forever and ever
move that oh okay sorry Mexican sorry
now what are you doing oh you can't lift
this one okay that's cool
don't worry Oh God oh [ __ ] we just made
it really hard for our self nice dude
that was sweet oh [ __ ] it's so hard okay
sorry he's I'm trying
sorry Mexican he needs to wait wait for
me to hold that oh my god why can't you
hear me do it again do you want me to do
it you need to do it he's giving up on
me
sorry gonna we were doing it
ah alright fine you do it then [ __ ]
out okay now there we go then do it
again
oh my god Mexicans need extra help man
there it is good job yay it's [ __ ]
awesome Mexican and Pitt's best friends
forever
so basically I'm playing a-line with a
purse anonymous person while millions of
you bros anonymous I guess ah no don't
say bye no no hello don't leave me
Mexican and them you this will be tricky
Mexican this will be very tricky Mexican
that's not gonna hold that Mexican I got
it nah damn it I will need ass more
solid base Mexicano oh my god he's he's
so diligent to build but he doesn't
think through what he does yeah it's
like he's almost a real mixie
okay we did it that's a great [ __ ]
tower let it go it Mexican you got it
yeah
this is so awesome oh no careful Mexican
blimey
okay we need to hold it up together I
think careful [ __ ] hell Mexican oh my
god we are struggling so much dammit
dammit dammit alright alright put that
down and then grab the other side of
this do it do it Mexican this is
teamwork there we go
proud of you buddy yes oh my god is so
good yeah
Oh huh um blimey Oh what if we lean them
towards each other what is he doing how
is he thinking okay oh [ __ ]
okay here we go huh
okay this is so [ __ ] awesome this is
probably one of the best puzzle games
I've ever played I don't know it's so
cool no don't go don't go Mexican you
can't leave me oh he's still here thank
God
all right Mexican don't worry I got this
don't you dare leave me Mexican aah he
just left we had all these memories
together what are you doing here
Christmas tree hello you're my new best
friend love you if you could just grab
these other things that'd be great
Mexican would have figured this out by
now damn it oh my god uh if you could
just if you could like do your job
that'd be great Mexican always did his
job okay okay he is actually pretty good
I'm sorry I misjudged you Christmas tree
you know what you're pretty cool that
was pretty cool teamwork amazing
teamwork yay yay you're my new best
friend
just like that I have a new best friend
we both went straight for it look we're
so eager to teamwork and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
tapped out no no I didn't even get to
say goodbye
damn it all right I'm gonna turn that
episode their really cool game I really
recommend you
checking it out a living link to a
description if you enjoyed this video
please go ahead and leave a like it
helps me out a lot leave a comment about
Mexicans and Christmas trees and I'll
see you pros in the next one as always
stay awesome bros